[Music]  6 26 on your wednesday morning got a  question about wide open spaces between  cars at stoplights viewer bridget writes  in my decades of driving i've never seen  so many people leaving one two even  three car lengths between them and the  car in front of them when they're  stopped at a light she writes this can  block cars from getting into turn lanes  and the drivers she says seem oblivious  as they look straight ahead at the chasm  in front of them what's going on  bridget i wish i knew a lot of us have  seen stuff like this and have wondered  the exact same thing so i want to open  up the conversation to anybody that does  leave a lot of space at stoplights  please write in tell us why do you do  that no judgment we're just curious the  email address right after i ask you to  buckle up drive carefully and please put  down that phone so here it is if  something's driving you crazy email me  traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com